show I don't know what she said but it
must have been Indian for handsome
devil there's murder in h Sage their
time is over I'm coming after oil don't
come near my family you pick a fight
with the wrong person I was sent to the
Bure BC about these
murders I need to kill these
men and killed my
family sir such an honor to chat with
you my first question why should fans
see killers of the flower moon in
IMAX well for me I made this film for
the big screen and IMAX is the big
screen that's all there is to it and uh
what I mean by the big screen is that
it's a spectacle but I think there's
more than simply a visual spectacle
although simply is maybe not the right
adjective but maybe not the right word
but there's a visual spectal but also
it's an internal spect spectacle and I
would love to be able to for an audience
together to be immersed in this film
immersed in this world so that it in
away Days Later weeks later maybe years
later there's still thoughts about it
that that that you know that resonate
with you and maybe in maybe enrich your
life in a way maybe they're questions
maybe they're questions maybe you have
five 10 different answers for those
questions but as you grow maybe the
questions your responses change and so I
found that we're great movies and I was
hoping that this is the kind of picture
like certain films I've seen like you
Michael Powell pressburger films certain
John Ford films certain felini films
that sort of thing I find that when I
see them later it's the same movie but
I'm finding other things yeah you know
yeah and so I hope that um the
experience of seeing this on that
wonderful screen on IMX is really going
to be something that they can all share
together well I think this was a great
film this is a great film I was blown
away by it too I really seriously we did
an interview with your DP Rodrigo uh and
we asked him about what his favorite
scene was any kind of behind the scenes
info about it so I wanted to share the
question with you and see what was your
favorite scene to shoot and if you have
any behind the scenes tidbits that would
be interesting well I mean we uh we
enjoyed shooting the wedding for one and
the boom up at the end as diniro was
preaching calling out to wak you know um
but there is one scene that is quite
something um
where Leo's character comes back into
the house after the explosion and he has
to tell Lily has to tell uh Molly that
it's her sister's house and we worked it
out that it's one take and the camera's
a point of view and he's just walking
through the house and you hear a child
calling Mommy Mommy Mommy which was real
was happening was a baby down downstairs
and and we go to the door and he opens
the door and you look down and they're
they hiding in the storm shell Al and
then Leo just she looks up he doesn't
say it's your sisters he doesn't say
anything he just goes shakes his head
and she knows and then
she it just some Primal scream comes out
which uh which is stunning for everybody
if you see and the the baby was crying
but everybody froze yeah everybody froze
for real yeah and you felt it too is not
M I thought that was really interesting
yeah um because we had planned it a
whole other way mhm and in fact we had
planted that we came in he came in the
house and they was there with the kids
and I said how could they be there in
the in the living room when the house
just blew up I mean they've got a where
could we go and somebody I think Lily
said there's there's a storm shelter I
said great and we went and we opened the
door and we looked down look at that
it's terrific and Rodrigo his face went
white because he he has to light
it and we hadn't planned
it that's funny I said can you do
something goes yeah okay and we did it
the same day so it worked that's
incredible I want to talk about your
fandom for a second because I've done a
lot of research on you and one question
that we have really liked to ask our
filmmaker friends is if there is any
movie that you could experience in IMAX
again or for the first time
theoretically what would it be and
why oh
my it's a tough one yeah it is I mean
having seen like Lawrence of
Arabia on on 70 millimeter in Vertigo in
70 millimeter I I've been there you know
I saw vertigo and uh high society and uh
um the searches and all those films in
Vista Vision projected in Vista Vision
yeah and that was quite an experience I
was 13 to 14 years old there's a film I
love called The Red
Shoes which uh we restored a few years
back and my edit thas gmake was married
to Michael Powell who was one of the the
filmmakers of it and I'm telling you the
color in that and the story still holds
up it's extra to see that in IMAX would
be amazing agreed agreed I always tell
people because I've done this a lot and
I've asked this question a lot I
actually say your film uh The Departed
it's The Departed nimax that's what I've
always wanted to see because that movie
specifically is the reason why I'm even
sitting in this chair really really so
that's interesting because that was a
tough picture to make yeah yeah I mean
the world tough but that that was
interesting appreciate it thank you so
much thank you okay
terrific